it was just a little bit of like a calm
before the storm people were waiting for
something very bad to occur Sydney
Australia is a very vibrant city
it is usually bustling seeing it so
stark is one of those things that you
would expect to see from one of those
apocalypse movies photographer going
about and doing a lot of daily jobs all
around sydney you could be a very good
transmitter of this virus you had to
change the way you learned about the job
gloves mask not touching people social
distancing and wiping down camera gear
the economic impacts have been massive
but certainly the mindset of the
population now is we can see the success
that has come from the mentality change
and people are still in a mood to to
come out of this successfully it was
really surreal I kept thinking how is
this real how can I be standing here
without being disturbed or jostled
India's lockdown is one of the strictest
in the world parks are closed you're not
allowed to go for walks there's no
public transport new trains no flights
some neighborhoods have even prohibited
deliveries and food takeout deliveries
even though the government has allowed
that and it's especially hard for
lower-income workers to access food and
shelter at this time the lockdown
certainly feels necessary because the
virus could spread so rapidly in a city
like Delhi because of how densely
populated it is and how much activity
goes on outside
but balancing it with making sure people
don't go hungry and you know their other
health conditions are attended to is
also critical it felt like that there
was this enormity of this moment for
these iconic spaces to be left to a
standstill that like just something
really terrible must have happened that
felt really really sad
while I was shooting in the empty
streets of downtown City I found that
the connection to the strangers who I
met who mostly essential workers was
much more intimate and sincere than it
usually is but all the people I met
security guards door clogs the doctor a
taxi driver it felt that everyone is
being especially kind and gentle and
sensitive to each other's stress and I
was really surprised and moved by that
softness Johannesburg is one of the most
unequal cities in the world during the
lockdown this inequality is put into
very sharp relief some neighborhoods
have quiet tree-lined streets with huge
houses and high walls and these
neighborhoods are like ghost town but
then there are many neighborhoods in the
city that are really crowded lots of
areas where people can't stay indoors
and do social distancing this lockdown
has shown how very precarious and
uncomfortable home is for so many South
Africans
some of these sites like the rug brigade
of the Holocaust Memorial are normally
crowded with tourists and in my
day-to-day life in normal times that
often is my second I may actually try to
avoid these areas because there's only
so many tourists walking around and it's
very very crowded
so work on this assignment was
interesting because the city felt like
to Sunday early morning
so everything was empty and there were
not many people out there was kind of an
eerie feeling I think if this lockdown
continues a lot longer it will be
definitely more challenging for us as a
business but also a follow of other
businesses aluminum like needs people to
get together honor to work but what
gives me hope this ethnicity has gone
through love and as always
when you walk in Midtown and there's
nobody and you're going to through Times
Square and there's nobody it throws you
off a little bit there's something that
doesn't that just doesn't feel right
doing this assignment was very
interesting because it gave me a chance
to see in New York that I've never seen
before
the places that I shot are very famous
places in New York City and they're
usually extremely crowded all of them
there are street vendors people walking
up and down there's loud trucks and cars
and it's very intense it's very
energetic but this time around it was
surprising to see how empty and how
quiet it was
all in all we're still kind of lucky in
the sense that we can still move we can
still walk around we can still go to the
park my friends and family in Italy are
stuck in their homes
I can't wait to go back to the New York
that I know crowded loud and and
sometimes annoying but also full of life
you